okay it's time for yet another example
of fake history an especially ghastly
one Juan Cole's 2018 book Muhammad
prophet of Peace amid the Clash of
Empires an academic at the University of
Michigan with a long history of fawning
over Islam Cole presents Muhammad in the
book as a contemporary Western Statesman
devoted to peace tolerance
multiculturalism and gender equality and
that he was sympathetic to the Christian
world that surrounded him I kid you not
Juan Cole essentially presents a
Muhammad of his own imagining or wishful
thinking to support his fanciful
portrait of Muhammad Cole rejects
mainstream Islamic historiography
relying instead on select Quran verses
unsourced folk memories as he calls them
plenty of academic conjecturing and
heavy use of the verb would for example
concerning the war between Rome and
Persia Cole writes quote Muhammad would
have watched with horror unquote
concerning the Persian Siege of
Jerusalem in 614 he writes Muhammad
would have listened with horror to the
reports of Travelers
unquote or he goes on quote Muhammad
would have been in acquainted with Roman
law culture and languages unquote and
quote Muhammad would have sent Envoy
seeking good relations with the new
Imperial authorities
unquote why the subjunctive tone would
oh because there's zero textual evidence
for such claims there is however plenty
of contrary evidence for example the
only record of relations between
Muhammad and the Eastern Roman Emperor
known as Byzantine hercus found within
the Islamic tradition that is the
prophet's order that the emperor abandon
Christianity and submit to Islam or face
war is not mentioned by Cole instead he
writes that Muhammad had allied with
Constantinople and went to his grave
that way in 632 even though there is no
evidence of any such Alliance because
Cole is at Great pains to present
Muhammad within the Western tradition
the best he admits to is that quote
Muhammad was occasionally forced into a
defensive campaign unquote and quote qu
the Quran allows Warfare only in
self-defense unquote long quotes from
Roman Statesmen Church fathers and even
European philosophers assert that
defensive war is just typically follow
such assertions about Muhammad as if to
say the violence the prophet engaged in
was exclusively defensive which after
all Western authorities permit in Cole's
view quote Arabic notion of jihad or
exertion for the sake of virtue was
paralleled in Aristotle platinus and the
New Testament unquote while Cole
Associates Islam with classical and
early Christian Notions of War he
frequently presents Islamic princip
principles as even more
humanitarian thus quote Christian law
helped create the endogamous Christian
race or Nation meaning it allowed
Christians to sort of marry only within
each other and be tribalistic whereas he
continues the law of the Quran creates a
rainbow race of
abrahamian
unquote this is because the Quran wait
for it quote celebrates gender and
ethnic diversity as an enrichment of
Human
Experience of course Cole forgets to
mention that the Quran permits husbands
to beat their wives and own sex slaves
check out Quran 434 and
43 at any rate mainstream Islamic
historiography flatly contradicts Cole's
revisionism it maintains that most of
Muhammad's wars were not defensive but
offensive and coercing non-muslims to
embrace Islam sometimes on pain of death
was quite the norm it also maintains
that Muhammad engaged in any number of
atrocities that would seem to contradict
just War
sensibilities for example assassinating
elderly men and women just because they
mocked him made verse about him or
torturing a Jewish man with fire until
he revealed his tribe's hidden treasure
and then having him decapitated anyway
and marrying his beautiful wife Safa
Cole dismisses all these unflattering
but amongst Muslims widely accepted
anecdotes he claimed quote the Quran
does not mention anything about a Mass
slaying of the men meaning the Jewish
men of kar and rather suggests that
deaths occurred during a battle but that
the Believers offered the enemy quarter
and took prisoners
unquote similarly Cole suggests that
Muhammad's well-known expulsion of Jews
is a later archetype based on quote
Christian expulsion of Jews in late
Antiquity unquote Muhammad's biographers
Cole insists must have projected this
Trope back onto Muhammad since quote the
few details in the Quran do not support
it unquote Cole's entire approach is a
gross and radical departure from how
Muslims have always ascertained
Muhammad's biography because the Quran
is notoriously ambiguous unch
chronological and mostly poetic from the
start Muslims needed to turn to other
sources chiefly the sir or biography and
the Hadith many vast volumes of accounts
of what Muhammad purportedly said and
did to piece together their prophet's
life that's what they turn to but even
Cole's exclusive Reliance on the Quran
does little to prove that Muhammad's
wars were purely defensive mainstream
Islamic exegesis maintains that the
Quran was revealed in three phases first
Muhammad's earliest years in Mecca when
he was vulnerable and outnumbered during
which he did indeed preach religious
tolerance for example Quran
2256 second phase muhamed's transitional
years when he began making alliances
outside of Mecca and preached
self-defense for example Quran
2239 and three Muhammad's last decade of
life from the year 622 to 632 when his
forces became stronger than and
overwhelmed his longtime meccan Rivals
during which time he preached going on
the offensive for example Quran 95 Cole
regularly quotes Quran verses from the
first two phases while conveniently
ignoring or reconfiguring those from the
third phase to conform to his portrayal
of a just- minded Prophet consider his
approach to Quran 9:29 which reads fight
those who do not believe in Allah in the
last day nor comply with what Allah and
his messenger have forbidden nor embrace
the religion of Truth meaning those who
do not Embrace Islam from among those
who were given the scripture until they
pay the jizya tribute willingly
submitting and fully humbled although
Islamic ex aesus has always interpreted
those who were given the scripture as
being Jews and Christians Cole tells
readers that this verse is actually
talking about fighting Pagan Arabs the
notion that it is referring to
Christians in Jews he says is quote
frankly
bizarre of course he fails to mention
that the very next verse following 929
9:30 makes perfectly clear that it is
talking about Jews and Christians as it
names them before adding may Allah
destroy them Cole later confesses in an
obscure endnote regarding his claim that
the verse is not referring to Christians
and Jews quote I should warn readers
that I am engaged in a radical Act of
reinterpretation here
nice try the vast majority of readers
will be ignorant of this important
caveat tucked away in the back of the
book moreover in the main text he writes
quote in my reading Quran 929 does not
have anything to do with a poll text on
Jews or Christians but rather demands
reparations from pagans guilty of
launching aggressive war of course no
one really cares about Cole's personal
reading of the Quran the fact is Muslims
have always interpreted 929 as
justifying the extortion of Christians
and Jews here's the most that Cole will
admit to concerning the third phase of
Muhammad's life when according to
traditional Islamic history the prophet
launched approximately nine raids per
year in search of power plunder and
slaves he writes quote in one of the
great ironies of History Muhammad who
had preached returning evil with good
and praying for peace for one's enemy
Muhammad was really Jesus don't you know
had violent conflict thrust upon him in
the last third of his prophetic career
the Quran maintains that he waged even
that struggle however in self-defense
and in the interests ultimately of trans
of restoring Tranquility the late
antique definition of just War Cole
further presents Muhammad's conquest of
and entry into Mecca as quote more
resembling the Reverend Martin Luther
King Jr's 1963 March on Washington than
a military
campaign maybe but King did not turn up
with 10 ,000 armed men threatening the
Denis of DC with a bloodbath if they did
not submit to his rule the way Muhammad
did to the meccans Cole needless to say
also whitewashes the early Arab
conquests from between 632 to 750 most
of which occurred over Christian
territory although eyewitnesses and
early chroniclers all write of De
Devastation and atrocities from Syria to
Spain Cole dismisses them as quote
exaggerated and hyperbolic unjustly
causing Islam to suffer from a black
Legend he also suggests that if excesses
were committed during the Arab conquest
or the Muslim conquest of the 7th
Century these were introduced by
Christian converts to Islam Who quote
brought into the new religion their own
longstanding practices of religious
violence in other words it was those
Christian converts to Islam who really
propelled the violence during the Muslim
Conquest Cole's book is a massive
Distortion meant for Western consumption
and Catering to Western sensibilities to
validate his thesis which is the
antithesis of what Muslims believe about
their prophet he either ignores or
manipulates the entirety of Islamic
historiography and konic
exegesis the book is in short another
abominable work of fake history sad to
say